hey everybody y'all doing okay great
my name is your nail Cochran thanks for
thanks for coming to my talk this talk
is about how to write code to induce
social change a very big problem but I
think together we can figure this out we
can do that today
so I'm not really good at the whole
introduction thing I don't really want
to talk about myself it's not about me
but you know just a little bit I am what
it's called a civic hacker I'm the
founder of sofa we're a civic tech
company based in Nashville I'm the
co-founder of black and tech Nashville
and I'm the senior infrastructure
engineer of Consular genetics so usually
people get up here and talk a lot about
their what they do on the day jobs but
I'm just gonna give you a quick overview
just in case you didn't read the bio
because it's long or whatever so I
started in optics neuroscience astronomy
mathematics and I go to all the best
conferences I have all the jobs and I
write all the code basically and kind of
sum it up they kind of started up I'm an
impatient millennial I want my freedom
from oppression right now while I have
the youth to enjoy it
[Applause]
okay so today's goals we definitely want
to examine inequality in society with
the technical lens we want to model the
solution and I want to coast curse
everyone here into being Civic hackers
as well and we're gonna have a little
fun and nerd out a little bit that's the
reason why I'm here at strange loopty to
fully just spread these wings right that
right quick okay let's start see if it
hacking so that means centrally we want
to protect the citizens from the
government sometimes sometimes the
government does things that are not in
our best interests and we got to kind of
have a back-up plan we want to help and
upgrade the government consider the
government as a system that is
upgradable meaning that due to our
involvement our civic engagement we're
able to patch bugs in that government
system we want to enhance societal
systems and whether it's patch those
societal systems as well and today we're
going to talk about patching a societal
system so before we really get into it
just know that there's gonna be some
regular text that's going to talk about
some practical meanings there's gonna be
some things in blue there are gonna be
some very nasty things for the math
heads here and then there's going some
things and thought bubbles because why
not of course
so hashtag inequality and society
inequality is a bug in American society
in my opinion it is what I call a hard
problem and we're going to define what
it means for it to be a hard problem
it affects thousands and it is not a
technical problem yes this is a
technical conference yes I'm a technical
minded individual and yes we are going
to use some technical tools to help make
this solution to that problem a little
bit easier okay so as a review hopefully
this is a review hashtag inequality is
when we have one set that's like man why
is the system so broken and then we have
another set that's of where the system
works on my machine
[Applause]
and that that difference that
differencing of user experience is in
itself not the problem the problem is
the next step is that there's little to
no effort to reconcile the differences
of music experience imagine that we have
PDF users in Chrome we have one great
experience and users in Firefox that
have not so great experience and then
what if all company was like you know
that would be sucky so we we want our
systems our societal systems our
government systems to be able to
reconcile those differences of user
experiences then that kind of makes me
sad that though that's this reality
exists you know I'm sure it's not
everyone may not feel sad but know hey
it's all of us so hopefully but what
makes this problem so hard right we know
it exists you're either a victim of it
or a witness of it so here are blockers
the motions of decision makers so
decision makers are anyone that hires
someone who influences policy who can
make a decision that could lead to that
split of user experience anybody so all
levels of society these decision-makers
exist and those emotions are the
blockers because sometimes the fact that
you have to consider there's a different
user experience for a different subset
of population may trigger you may be
like I'm not a mean I'm not a nasty
person why do I have to think more about
this group that's are not so privileged
and that idea that thought process may
be triggering then there's the
unconscious bias something that we don't
have control over
we're restrained and then there's the
lack of direction given that it's the
the scope of this problem is so large
like where do you even start it's so
daunting so those are our blockers and
we're gonna release those blockers today
so in order to do that we essentially
need a series of decisions made in the
right direction so
I'm not going to enforce there has to be
that we agree on what those directions
may be I'm not going to enforce what the
decision should be but I'm going to say
that we just need those decisions to
happen in all those different directions
different forms of equality require
different decisions at different points
okay and this is what it's called a
decision problem I'm scoping it as a
decision problem hopefully to make it
easier for us technologists so our
intuition hashtag intuition tells us
that technology could help us address
inequality and other societal problems
that just are feels but I feels doesn't
solve problems it's a start
it made it motivate us but in itself
doesn't really do anything
hashtag hypothesis so modern technology
enables oppressed populations to verify
solutions of isis's of inequality in
reasonable time and an in reasonable
time part it's very important because
that means that we can get an answer
pretty quickly and I feel that the
masses can build the tech we have an
entire Internet mostly running on open
source software I think we can build
something that could help solve this
problem I think it's within our
wheelhouse and I can't do it by myself
I wish I could but I really need your
help so let's collaborate it's gonna
take combinations of data and effort so
there are many instances of inequality
if you consider inequality in society as
a class then there are multiple
instances of hashtag inequality for
example there are disparities in
treatment by police right this is a
review
digital access
not everyone has internet access not
everyone can afford internet access now
everyone live in a place where there are
service providers that is a disparity
and income disparity based upon your
gender and race and ethnicity you may
get paid differently as soon as you sign
that offer letter they've lied to you
sorry okay we're going to use the
variable T a and Y to represent the
effort to correct the disparity that's
what we're going to do here for the math
is so income disparity so this
visualization is from information this
beautiful net
it displays the gender pay gap in the
United States and those two areas if you
can really see that that that like text
is the disparity between across gender
when it comes to senior executives as
well as technologists it's pretty huge
it's large this data is from 2015 why
this doesn't make sense
right we can count we have machines that
can count while we have this problem so
the effort to fix this is called
variable Y so the right effort with with
the right effort oppressed populations
will be able to answer yes to has income
disparity been minimized this is again
framing this as a decision problem and
yes has to be given in reasonable time
meaning that it can't take the rest of
my life time for us to just check the
answer not to get the not to create the
answer go approvers enter solution but
just to check the previously provided
solution we just be able to check our
work fast okay so how will we know if
our efforts worked that's being able to
check whether an I efforts has worked
pretty quickly allows us to iterate
quickly that's the reason why testing is
in poor
in software if you your see your
continuous integration system is able to
run your test quickly then you're able
to iterate faster being able to check
whether or not your efforts on the job
has worked and that answer that brings
us to NP complexity where decision
problems where the yes answer whether
there are yes answers can be verified
and what is called a computationally
deterministic manner okay
they like those words the computer
science just loves those words all those
syllables but it really means that we
can just check our code check out our
work quickly with code that's really all
that means and here's the formal
hypothesis is that all instances of
inequality in society are in the set of
NP problems yeah I said it and we're
going to walk through a light proof of
that instances in society are in the set
NP we're going to do that together okay
so I'm going to pick one income
despairity who wants to see a solution
for income Society click all those hands
alright let's do it I'm up for the
challenge
so models matter my background in
physics and physics have taught me that
physicists really are awesome because
they are really good at building models
like you don't have an idea of what
you're really dealing with but you kind
of can like draw a picture or kind of
like there's no scoped out the behavior
a little bit so that you can kind of
guess what it kind of works on the
inside how it works on the inside so the
act of building models and testing you
gets those models you've created it's
definitely a unique skill of physicists
they're awesome in that way so our model
is that we're gonna I'm going to say
that distributive effort can vary we're
going to use distributive effort to
verify the solutions of minimizing the
income disparity okay that's our model
I'm not saying it works I'm just saying
that's what we're starting this is our
starting point
so in order to do that we're gonna have
some tools I'm gonna pull some things
out my toolbox first is human empathy we
got that right we got that right
least some of us I'm gonna use the
complex plane it's one of my favorite or
tools for mathematics and we're gonna
use the geographic coordinate system
we're gonna call that G that very
special squiggly G we're gonna have code
slash policy the reason why I say policy
on that bullet point is because policy
is a form of code okay we can see that
it's not too far-fetched and we're gonna
have crowdsource data so data from
everybody we already give our data to
you know billion-dollar companies all
the time for free we can give it a
little bit more around to tour it's
evolving a problem I think we can so
that's all we need here
so yes first coordinate system the
geographic coordinate system because why
humans live on earth right this just
sanity check we got a sanity check we
can't have too many large leaves here
then the complex plane if you remember
this from any of your math classes if
you took those math classes we're always
going to have that and we're gonna use a
tool very special tool one of my
favorites from mathematics called a
Riemann sphere the Riemann sphere allows
us to centrally do map the GPS
coordinates to the complex plane we all
remember what functions are right in the
mathematical sense functions require a
set of inputs that map to a set of
outputs now how we do that mapping can
be algorithmically or it could be with a
plano table both are mappings both
demonstrate functions okay and of course
in computer science that function would
have a function signature right okay and
so for the math hares we're just
defining a mapping so that's what that
is that's all the function is we're
mapping from one coordinate system to
the other
and that little and that equation at the
bottom here
what we're doing taking two inputs of
latitude longitude and latitude and
creating a complex number
now all that really means is that we can
just wrap the earth in the complex plane
kind of like just wrapping a present
where the top of the earth the North
Pole is like infinity so we're just
wrapping it that's the best graphic I
could find but that's the only graph
that I could find so hey there it is and
that really means we can draw lines this
is so important
mathematicians love drawing lines
specifically things called boundaries
that that is very important concept in
mathematics and the fact that we can
draw these lines on the Earth's surface
means that the complex plane it's dense
on the earth now density is a technical
term in mathematics it's also technical
term in physics not the same meaning
same word different innings okay this
city in mathematics means that for any
two geographical points on the earth no
matter if we're talking about between
st. Louis or Nashville or between myself
this stage and that door there's always
going to be a complex number in between
those two points that's what my mapping
does so for any points on the earth
there's always a complex number in
between them okay
there is density that's Gucci that's
Gucci now remember humans live on the
earth for now and sometimes in cities
and that means that we can draw on the
earth clothes paths this map is a
outline of Davidson County Davidson
County is the exact same boundary of the
city of Nashville that's not true for
every city a good example where that's
not true is Memphis where the city
boundary of Memphis is not the same
thing as the boundary of Shelby County
but for some cities this is the case
it's called a consolidated boundary by
census
so we can call these clothes clothes
paths these clothes paths are very very
awesome in the complex plane that allow
you to do a lot of things because you
can draw a line and there'll be no gaps
so where our effort goes everyone
including the oppressed group must be
able to submit data and then one person
at least one person builds a chart yes
the slide says one person but we just
need at least one person build a chart
that's it using d3 or whatever you want
it's fine this is where our effort as
technologists and citizens go now you
have a small target smaller target
simple charts are deterministic there
can be calculated in reasonable time
even with very very large datasets
even with datasets that change every
second the results of deterministic
therefore income disparity is in the set
of P thus it is proven done so recap
that was easy
right that was easy all we have to do is
just make sure that we provide coding
data for this problem we examined
inequality through a technical lens we
acknowledge very ever so slightly that
social problems may require technical
work and non technical work right we
know that we did some maths and we did
our proof now bonding so far yeah it's
gravy it's real easy it's hard problem
hard but wait income disparity does not
equal all of inequality in society so
how could I even say this done yes I did
one proof for income disparity
specifically but boundaries matter okay
so that all that allows us is saying
that any closed boundary any city-county
contains a set of instances of
inequality every city has an instance of
income disparity every city has an
instance of disparity and treatment by
the police every city have it in every
city in rural area and County inside of
it has an instance of disparities and
digital access those sex exists within
those clothes boundaries so I'm invoking
the axiom of choice so if you don't know
what the action with choice is that's
fine for those who question my use of
the axiom of choice I'm going to explain
it to you and if you want me to go in
depth after the talk cool yeah just meet
me in the hallway somewhere around the
coffee works out so that means I can
pick all the instances of inequality in
any certain any set in any city in any
closed boundary in any order that I want
starting with income disparity boom
that's Gucci what there is a choosing
function that choosing function is based
upon maybe whatever arbitrary thing at
it that I pick
I'm just do all of I'm just starting
with income disparity maybe because for
me it may be the simplest to solve but
what about the other other types of
effort that will need to be given when
it comes to other instances of
inequality we can't use the same effort
for income disparity that we would use
for disparity around treatment by police
or by digital access well in those cases
I can just tell you what we would do
okay so when it comes to treatment by
belief right we'll first need to have
understanding
of the routes of the police second we'll
have to know where the location of the
precincts okay and third we have to have
an idea based upon what police officers
interacted with which individuals that
led to death so that may give us an idea
of which precincts to focus our efforts
because across any city including you
know st. Louis every precinct is not
behaving in the exact same manner or
providing the exact same statistics
around treatment of people of color so
we might need to target our efforts a
little bit that data that we can cry out
we can crowdsource tells us where to put
our non technical effort we might need
to go talk to the police chief
of a certain place of a certain sergeant
in a certain precinct not all of them
okay when it comes to digital access we
care about what income would internet
providers are there where people whether
the the location or the distribution of
population in them in a city right we
know that there are metropolitan areas
but we know that people live outside of
metropolitan areas as well so the
density of population matters also the
backbone of fiber backbone matters what
also matters is the policy that is used
to even deliver the services for example
in Nashville Google Fiber wanted to come
they're still coming it's been a long
time coming still coming and no
telephone poles is how you send
information it's how you send you know
data but you know they have to put
things on the poles and everybody just
can't do that there's laws around there
so yeah so those parameters are city
specific oh I can say boundary specific
because it's not just cities so boundary
specific rules determine where our
efforts should go
if the crowdsource this data a lot of
data being even provided by you all or
provided by your local governments
through open data yes that is Gucci and
so we have ways to say regardless of
what order of instances of inequality
that I pick or
you pick that everybody can pick an
instance of inequality there can all be
different instances and to provide an
effort towards solving that problem so
we know where to place our efforts right
depending on the problem that you care
about now this leverage leverage is hard
on how open source development is
successful it's a collaborative effort
now everyone cares that much about the
Linux kernel sorry
not everyone's submitting code to the
Linux kernel some people are submitting
code to JavaScript I mean some people
are some people are writing react fine
but we care at different levels some
people are not able to commit core code
some people willing to write
documentation some people are willing to
just find the bugs just find them some
people are just willing a thumbs up the
bugs yeah
oh that's important give me a plus give
me a plus one if that's really a bug
that helps so everybody cares in
different magnitudes about different
things and the aggregate effect gets us
to change if we are directional or if we
are intentional with our use of our data
and effort so I think everyone in here
can be a civic hacker everyone outside
of this room can also be a civic hacker
everyone in the whole wide world can be
a civic hacker yes even grandma yeah and
we have a way to check our work quickly
we can iterate on this fast a homework
for the class you know homework for the
class is how do I write a unit test for
this but you know that's not today next
time so I don't really I'm not sure I'm
not sure if this isn't here any of this
will work but
thank you